[creator] okay so new update I have more agents working on the fixes I was just talking
[creator] about the changes so making things actually 3d I have a new creative
[creator] director agent that is going to be referencing the images that I gave it
[creator] that are right here if I open these I should be able to go through them
[creator] literally just grab these from Steam
[creator] so we'll see what it does
[creator] I have one for UI because I want a better UI
[creator] an agent for sound design
[creator] and then one for
[creator] this one should be the one that simulates
[creator] uh... gravity
[creator] and other things like that
[creator] as well as actually making the entire
[creator] map I guess
[creator] uh... actually
[creator] infinite basically
[creator] Yeah, an infinite universe. It's literally right there in front of my face.
[creator] So everything will be procedurally generated.
[creator] Yeah, and I think I already mentioned this one.
[creator] But having actual 3DS sets with 3JS.
[creator] So we'll see how long this takes.
[creator] And then I'll report back.